[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000 as always my name is Caleb Denby
and I'll be your driver on this journey
today I wanted to take a look at Fabiano
Cara wanna in his games from the end of
the Tata Steel Masters Tournament course
Bobby ended up winning this tournament
with an astounding score which I do not
remember I feel like it was something
like ten points he was doing well in the
tournament pretty much pretty
consistently throughout but then in the
last three rounds he actually won all
three of his games to round out the
tournament pretty pretty professionally
so those are the games I wanted to take
a look at today but before I get started
there was some questions will the road
to mm be coming back next week the
answer for you YouTube viewers is no
we're not gonna be live-streaming the
class during the Karen's Cup because you
guys will have plenty of chess content
to see as far as in person here if you
want to come out to the club to see it
it depends on when the round ends likely
it will be will be canceled
with that in mind let's move on to
today's lecture the first game I want to
look at is the game between Vladislav
Kovalev against Fabi Karen Juana and in
this game Bobby had black and started
off in the Royal apes' which I'm sure
most of you have seen before black plays
a6 Bishop a4 Knight f6 the the old
mainline castles black kicks this Bishop
away with b5 gaining some space on the
Queen side bringing this bishop to this
diagonal but sometimes it turns out to
be a weakness just basic royal Lopez
stuff Bishop c5 black gets developed
white chooses c3 aiming to eventually
kick this bishop away with d4 black
plays d6
and now we see a four so this idea of b5
actually being a little bit weak comes
into play
why it uses it as a hook if you remember
from from last lecture to try and open
up space on the Queen side but it's not
a huge deal in this case Fabi chooses
rec b8 defending this pawn and we are
well within theory still white now does
expand in the center with d4 black
simply retreats
in this case you don't really want to
open things up because mainly your king
isn't castled yet and it gives white
some ability in the center for example
even immediately if things like a five
might might come onto the board so not
captures but instead simply Bishop b6y
it takes on b5 opening up the a file now
we see Knight a3 is White's choice to
develop this Knight it asks black it a
difficult question here how do you
defend this pawn and the answer is I
don't you can have that pawn so white
captures the pawn black gets developed
and once again this is actually all
still theory and just to quickly talk
talk about the idea here the open B file
is going to give black some very decent
compensation in addition to the fact
that with the time White's spent
capturing this pawn this Knight was
unable to come to d2 to defend this this
extra night here so this pin is gonna be
slightly more annoying than it normally
would be because both this bishop in
this knight are unable to defend so this
is where the blacks compensation is
coming from the main move here is Bishop
C to d5 has also been played white
Kovalev chose the third most popular
option which is rook e1 black Bobby goes
ahead and captures here if you play
Queen takes I believe there's a problem
on the d4 square
so instead pawn takes tries to hold
everything together and now Knight h5 is
the way to take advantage of this F for
weakness created by G takes f 3 of
course the doubling of the pawns weakens
not only the pawns but the squares in
front of the pawns as well this pawn
unable to come to g3 now to stop this
Knight
and so we see Knight h5 and I kind of
blew past the the first part of this
game but it was it was all theoretical
this was some deep opening prep but
let's talk a little bit about this
position here so what's going on here
well white does have an extra pawn we'll
call it this this B to pawn for the
moment
and in exchange for it as I said this
pin on the night was slightly awkward
and so black was able to fracture the
white pawn structure and get this
nice-looking outpost on f4 for his
pieces and so what should both sides be
trying to do here there's kind of a role
that is is set for each side by
accepting a gambit like this so what is
black trying to do and what is white
trying to do let's let's discuss so
let's start with with black what is what
is black trying to do in this position
both specifically or just general ideas
I'll give you a little bit to think
hiding the notation for the the cheaters
in the class so any any ideas for either
side here yeah yeah he's kind of
telegraphing his hand here with this
night coming in so you said storming the
Kings side which is a good way to put it
I suppose so what that means is a lot of
things moves like Knight f4 are going to
come you see these pieces on the
queenside can actually kind of shift to
the Kings side as well you might see
this Knight also make an appearance on
the f4 square and this Bishop while on
the on the Queen side is a very long
range piece and if the pressure to d4 is
ever so great that it feels the need to
move this bishop is going to be looking
at an f2 pawn which is very relevant in
addition this Queen might come out to h4
and you might see even an f5 push trying
to get a rook into the game as well so
these are ideas that should be coming
through being tossed around in blacks
head so you got the general idea and so
the next step is to find those specifics
which is the difficult part and chess
quite often is is finding the specific
ways you want to go about your plan in
this case Fabi of course started with
this move Knight h5 aiming for the f4
square now even more general than that
when you do sacrifice the pawn it's
important to find targets to play for
you don't want to just kind of let your
opponent get everything under control so
you need to be playing actively so
storming the Kings side in this case is
is one way to do that and that's kind of
what Fabi does in this game but he also
finds this out this activity this target
somewhere else on the board which I
won't spoil just yet we'll see it later
in the game conversely as white the most
general way to put it when you've
accepted upon sacrifice the word you'll
hear most often is consolidate white is
looking to consolidate so this is the
opposite of what Black's trying to do
white is trying to regain his own
activity and limit black's activity
once the activity is kind of leveled out
again white will simply be up upon so if
white can manage to do that in some way
while keeping his material edge that's
the ideal but also you'll quite often
see strong players very very happy to
give the material back this is one of
the best things about being up material
especially if it's a lot of material is
if you're up material you always have
this option to give some of it back in
order to create your own weaknesses or
activate your own pieces so generally in
this position the main move has been
king h1 keeping the extra pawn for white
and simply preparing moves like rook g1
to find activity on the G file this is
the way that that white has tried to
solve these problems in the past in the
game Duda who is playing white here oh
no I'm sorry Kovalev who's playing white
here at dude is in the next game
actually chose this move f4 and the idea
with this is to consolidate a little bit
but we'll see it actually turned out to
not be the best way to go about things
he was a bit too hasty to give the
material back so the obvious move for
black of course since Knight is attacked
and the knight attacks this pawn so we
see Knight xf4
in white responds with Bishop takes f4
and this was his point he wanted to
divert in this black centre pawn to f4
and claim that now he has a nice little
Center and this is how he has
consolidated now he has a big Center he
doesn't have to worry about pieces
coming to f4 and he's saying that this
exchange of the bishop for the knight
really cuts down black's opportunities
on on the King side for for an attack
here with that in mind how do you think
Fabi continued to approach this position
now that this this decision has been
made for white black now has his pawn
back so he doesn't have to go quite
all-out on the Kings side so to speak
and so how can he find other targets
what other targets might there be for
black to look at here
I'll give you a moment but yeah any idea
yet the B file is a great point there's
a lot of pressure here to be sure and so
black just has to look to find some
specifics on how to kind of shake loose
these pieces to get at to get out the
weaknesses notably this Bishop seems to
be in in the way for the moment as well
as we don't have a great way to actually
open up the file to attack these pieces
so how could we go about doing something
like that let's try to find the
specifics now as well it doesn't have to
be a one move thing just just a
long-term plan
yeah yeah exactly this night seems to be
the problem piece right once we move
this night let's say to e7 what does
that allow us to do next yeah you can
push the C pawn either to c6 or c5 then
that gives this bishop the opportunity
to drop back to c7 it might even help
attack d4 and it's allowing when
suspicion moves out of the way the rook
to look at the B pawns
so we'll see in the game white actually
starts with King h1 still a very nice
smooth he wants to bring this rook to
the G file and now Fabi does continue
with 97 a very logical move white
something the danger on the B file
starts to divert his pieces away from it
but now after c6 or Ansari Knight g6
first I'm defending f4 defending a 5 we
see b4 from white so this is how you
know white paying attention has noticed
fabi's threats and has played b4 to try
and and nullify the effects of some of
that but now we see c6 and after night
a3 what do you think Bobby's next move
is so so white has accurately dealt or
yeah accurately dealt with all these
threats to the B file what's next for
black here what can black do to still
pry open some targets and find activity
and yeah that's actually a great point
back when white played king h1 I think
Queen g5 might have been a threat which
also is a good reason to play king h1
so there's one move which actually
improves both of these minor pieces
depending on what white does which seems
kind of funny because these pieces are
very far apart
and you can even make the claim that it
improves this piece
yeah that's exactly right so these two
pieces together specifically this pawn
in this pawn are kind of stunting all of
the black pieces this Knight would love
to be on the e5 square this is like the
ideal square for this Knight it
blockades this pawn keeps this Bishop
out of the game
I is plenty of squares in White's camp
this Bishop would love to look at this
f2 pawn but these pawns are in the way
in this rook would love to be at
actually attacking this before upon but
once again the c3 pawn is kind of in the
way so because of that the best move for
black is to play a c5 the black fob you
first started with c6 just to get this
Knight out of the game a little bit and
now he moves long moves ahead with c5
and he's going to loosen all of these
squares so let's start with well let's
see in the game
white started with B takes e5 in order
to solve this weakness on b4 so we'll
start with that but now let's talk about
what the problem is with one taking or
two playing d5 because those are very
natural ways to deal with the pressure
to the pressure of this Bishop so what's
wrong with with taking this is actually
I think the worst of the options what
was that
well you're offering a trade of the
Queen's shirt but I'm not sure black
wants to take so we won't even put that
on the board just yet of course Bishop
takes c5 is eventually going to be
played you can insert you can insert a
queen shirt if you want but then what's
the big deal
what why is this so bad for white
yes so great wolf in the YouTube chat
has most most of the reason why yeah so
it's the the pawn structure specifically
like we were saying it's this a five
square for the night
first of all f2 is attacked so you have
to do something about it
I don't care if you want to play f3 or
Rock f1 or Ricky - let's just say f3 now
ninety five is going to come and this
actually permanently kind of ruins ruins
this white Bishop here it's always going
to do suck going to be stuck behind this
pawn f3 is going to be under pressure
things like Queen h4 are going to be
threats and King side pressures is still
going to be very relevant in addition to
that you actually also leave yourself
with a weak c3 pawn as well but that's
kind of secondary to this V five square
being the problem so D takes T five is
the worst d5 is also bad for a very
similar reason ninety five is going to
be a strong move once again and you can
play see for if you don't say your q1
I'll play C for myself and you'll have
similar problems against f2 but c4 isn't
really a move you want to play it just
adds another weakness for this this
night to be attacking so d5 and taiks
are both really not great so what white
does in the game is probably his best
option he tries to let this tension just
stand
he plays Knight c4 fob he goes ahead and
captures black or white takes the
opportunity to take this Bishop but now
after rook takes and pawn takes white
actually still has all of the same
problems here he managed to get rid of
one of the minor pieces which is
somewhat helpful but it doesn't really
fix that the permanent damage to to his
structure so what what is fabi's next
move here yes to play pretty quickly to
prove that that White's pieces are not
going to be better
first of all let me let me actually just
as kind of a hint let me show why you
have to play quickly here let's say you
pass right after the move e5 this rook
defends the center this Bishop is
completely opened up and you really have
you have nothing to do with your pieces
here white would be much better I think
after h6 and and E 5 this looks pretty
good pretty good for the white player so
that's what you're trying to avoid
things like that happening so how can
you kind of force White's hands into
making a structural structural defect or
a weakness
what do you think
no ideas yeah yeah so we can start with
York d6 Bobby does actually another okay
for now here's the slightly more
difficult thing to solve here you still
would love to stop this a five move some
way if you can but it's not totally easy
to and you want to somehow add more
pressure to this deep on and fabi's next
move actually does both of these things
it doesn't immediately apply pressure to
the d4 pawn but it's preparing to and
very quickly I wanted to say Rock i-4 is
the best way of defending this pawn of
course the other way is to play the move
d5 but I think everybody here should
know by now why black is hoping for this
and that reason is so the bishop in the
knight both those answers are correct
it's the e5 square this blocks in the
bishop forever this night will be very
very happy on e5 influencing the Kings
side also eyeing the Queen side if need
be and black is going to be very happy
in this endgame perhaps though this is
this is kind of blacks or rights best
try here because we'll see what happened
in the game later but in a position like
this generally the winning idea for
black is going to be to use this kind of
majority on the Kings side you're gonna
see moves like g5 come on the board and
black can honestly just sit with h6 and
g5 for a while and try maneuver these
pieces to the Kings side through through
this Queen side on occasion but it's
going to be very very uncomfortable for
white and there's always going to be
threats of pushing even further two
squares like g4 and g3 but it would have
been a very very different game if white
had played d5 d5 is just so the type of
movie you won't see strong players make
very often because it's admitting you
know I'm gonna have an awful in game
that nobody wants to play and generally
we see Fabiano win those games so
instead white attempted Rick a four for
the moment which forces black to find
this next move which is very very good
and so this is I don't know if I would
call it a puzzle but it is kind of
though the best move to show why black
has an edge here so I'll give you just a
little bit to find it and then we'll
we'll go ahead and move on
so keeping in mind this is the key move
we're trying to stop and we also want to
add pressure to d4 somehow so people in
YouTube do do have it but they're
they're pretty strong players sometimes
anybody in the room want to give it a
shot yeah that's exactly right
so shout-out to Dan Cruz so Mar Cory the
jet the the Jackie the Jackie era
everybody loves every one person types
and then the rest just copy oh my but 95
anyways is a great move as always my
favorite way to stop and move in chest
is to make it illegal
so with E 5 being illegal White's not
going to play it hopefully of course the
idea is there's this nice pin on the
Queen to take advantage of so 95 is
played wait continues with f3 and then
the point of blacks play is this next
move so 95 is useful because it allows
this night to go to where
of course knight c6 adds a third
attacker to this pun and there's simply
no way to add a third defender so now
White has to make a decision d5 is still
playable but of course we've seen black
will simply play back 295 and the
pressure on f3 and the pressure on the
Kings side it's going to make for I
think a technically lost endgame
although it will take quite a bit of
technique to prove it instead Duda went
for a 5 with the idea of opening up this
bishop
Kovalev yes I keep saying Duda but but
Duda is in the next game it is less love
Kovalev all right Lee 5 opening up the
bishop but of course this is now
jettisoning this pawn on d4 so we do see
rook takes rook takes and now Knight
takes in after Bishop b4 this Queen
comes out to h4 a nice little a nice
move we'll call it a tactic to make sure
that the Queen's stay on the board which
is going to be favorable for black
considering this King is a lot more
exposed than this King of course you
can't take the knight do to Queen takes
in one and it is unpinning so it lets
you knight move so so Queen h4 is a nice
move we now see your q1 rook d8 and
fabi's is simply much better here in
technically winning Queen f1 Bobby
continues with g6
just levy a ting some of this pressure
rook g4 is black stripe this Queen comes
back to e7 the rook does capture on f4
but now after Queen e5 or gauge 496 you
actually see here the night kind of
outshines this this Bishop just a little
bit this f4 squares is always going to
be very very strong and now with this
rook on this open file the end is kind
of near rook h3 was Kovalev smooth we
see native for your Chi 3 and now rook
d2 and white actually threw in the towel
in this position here and as to why he
specifically chose this moment I suppose
things like Queen h4 are coming with a
lot of force things like we
be - are also coming the second-ranked
is just kind of indefensible for for
white here I think we got someone
peeking in the door but no worries so
any questions about this game
there was one earlier on that I wanted
to check back in on but before I do that
and any other questions so this is yeah
that's that's an excellent question this
is one of those games that that really
makes you think about how strong Fabiana
Cara Juana is did white do anything
wrong and it's difficult to tell I was
actually asking myself the same question
before teaching this lecture one thing
is that this f4 idea probably just isn't
the best way to consolidate black really
it doesn't have any problems after f4
and Fabi showed showed why here black
still has activity and now white simply
just doesn't have an extra pawn to show
for it
granted the plans do change for black
after f4 compared to just King h1 as
normal so it did kind of force black to
play a little bit creatively but Bobby
rose to that challenge very very nicely
hi welcome come in and in addition to
that well I don't think white is like
losing here there were some inaccurate
moves for one the pressure on this B
file probably wasn't quite quite so
relevant to call for Bishop c2 bishops
on a nice diagonal kind of pressuring
the Kings side and maybe white should
have played a little bit quicker
with with rook g1 immediately play might
have continued very very close to how
the game happens but then that brings me
to White's next mistake is even after
Bishop c2 night g6 you can still play
rook g1 here and things are pretty
similar but this move b4 I think really
gives gives black a little bit of an
edge because after something like g1 if
you continue the same way with c5 now
after let's say Knight c4 takes and the
game goes exactly the same way
let's let's see here what's the
difference the difference is this pawn
on d6 is still alive and while Rick
takes b2 might happen in this case this
pawn on d6 actually takes away all of
White's pressure to to the d4 pawn and
so I'm sorry
even after before then my last point is
B takes e5 is actually a pretty huge
mistake because you do need this pawn on
d6 for black to help alleviate some of
this pressure maybe a little bit better
would have been going in for something
like this and actually just sacrificing
this pawn and keeping this pawn on d6 so
you can keep this pawn on d4 so you
still have ideas of playing v5 later in
the future it's not going to be
comfortable for white but it isn't going
to be losing I think is as my claim so
these are some mistakes that I think
white actually what actually made so I
think B takes e5 was was a pretty key
mistake for for white here and then
later on when things started actually
really really really going wrong Bobby I
think might be technically winning here
but
Kovalev didn't really put up the the
most astute defense things like rook g1
weren't quite the best move maybe
White's should try to find activity over
here on the Queen's side but it's a very
very difficult position to play so it's
it's understandable why things went
wrong earlier somebody wanted me to go
over just quickly what happens on Queen
takes f3 I'm just gonna cheat to make
sure I don't say anything wrong so he
takes d4 C takes d4 yeah it is just this
this pawn on d4 ends up hanging and now
what black still does have some nice
pressure on the Queen side so that's why
after Bishop takes f3
we need this Queen here and so we see G
takes f 3 so those are some mistakes
that I think kovalev couple have kind of
made this f4 idea probably just isn't
the greatest for white in this opening
and Fabi rose to the occasion with that
in mind why don't we finally move on to
this Fabiano Duda game since I think
dude as his opponent in just every game
here
in this game Fabiano actually had white
and Judah is playing with the black
pieces and Duda
I'm favi chose to play d4 and we
actually got a Catalan so I'm going to
kind of blow past these opening moves
here it's the main line Catalan and I'll
talk a little bit about opening once we
get going
so after D takes c4 there's a few main
moves for White Queen c2 Queen a4 and 95
all with the idea of regaining this pawn
in some manner eventually 95 ends up not
really regaining the pawn like that but
Queen c2 in 24 that's definitely the
idea these days Queen c2 is the main
option for white and the reason is after
Queen a4 a6 Queen takes c4 and b5 is is
the main line and with Queen c2 after a
6 White has the extra option to play a 4
because the Queen isn't there and so
this is why Queen a4 is is the most era
Queen c2 is the most popular because of
this extra option that being said
against Queen c2 c6 is now one of the
main moves and you get a similar-looking
line with b5 here so in the game they
did a little bit of funny business Bobby
did bring the Queen out to a for
allowing this a6 line but due to still
opted to play c6 instead which isn't the
most common but after Queen c4 and b5 is
simply transposing to that line after
Queen c2 so ok that is all to say
they're still in theory they just did
some funny business along the way now
Queen c2 is the most popular move but
Fabi chose Queen b3 so let's let's pause
here because this is kind of out out of
the main territory of the Catalan
already so just just some things to note
White has played c4 black has captured
c4 in this line White has managed to
regain the pawn and so there is material
equality and all that's left to look at
is the difference in the in the position
in the pieces and in the pawn structure
so what's going on here
what is white aiming to do with with the
Catalan let's start with what is white
aiming to do we can talk just general
rather than specific moves here yes and
no white has drawn out this pawn to b5
on the Queen side and so the main idea
for white is in fact to put pressure on
the Queen's side b5 you can say is is an
over extension but but yeah white is
looking to make use of the Queen side
weaknesses and to challenge them and the
key piece for white is going to be this
light squared bishop on the long
diagonal this is where most of what we
can call the Catalan pressure
that's the the Domesday kind of term for
it White has the lurking Catalan
pressure it usually comes from this
bishop and from some major pieces
eventually coming to the Queen side as
well so that's exactly right white is
looking to put pressure on the Queen
side meanwhile in many many openings for
black where you end up with a structure
with pawns on c6 and e6 what are the
main breaks that that black looks to
achieve to kind of equalize
the main pawn breaks will we'll say
any ideas
yes c5 is is the main one and then
rarely you'll see not you probably won't
you wouldn't expect it from this
position but II five as well is also a
very nice pawn break the point is white
has this extra central space and that's
what's causing a lot of blacks problems
here for his pieces and for especially
this pawn on c6
and so blacks should strive to challenge
this pawn whether it be with c5 which is
usually more achievable or e5 which in
this case looks less achievable because
White's Knight is well placed to
challenge this square with that in mines
obviously playing a move like c5
immediately is pretty suicidal you're
opening up this Bishop and you haven't
developed your queen side at all
so black plays this move Bishop e7 and I
did want to talk about Queen Queen b3 a
little bit as well
Queen c2 being the main move keeps more
pressure on c6 I think with Queen b3
Fabia's is simply saying rather than
challenging the c6 pawn he's going to be
challenging the b5 pawn and that means
you can expect moves like a four maybe
later in the future and you can also
expect it to make c5 a little bit more
difficult to achieve because this b5
pawn is going to face going to face
capture so black just continues
naturally plays Bishop b7 white also
continues naturally Yorick d1 supports
the center perhaps it frees this knight
to come to e5 we see Knight bd7
black does get developed and now white
makes the key decision in this game and
plays Knight e5 allowing for a change in
structure so black rises to the occasion
plays Knight takes e5 and pawn takes e5
Knight d5 looks like a very natural move
but of course is a huge mistake
how does white win here it's a pretty
simple tactic
and I trust you guys to find this one
anybody see it white wins apiece
well it's like nights III in the sense
that it attacks this night but it is not
night C 3 e 4 of course you simply
attack the pinned piece and listen I
can't move Black is losing so fabi's
idea is that this change of structure
forces this night back to D 7 or it's a
little bit safer a little bit closer to
home and makes the black pieces a little
bit awkward and this is actually a
pretty common idea that you'll you'll
see in Catalan type positions this
tonight comes to e5 and black sometimes
decides to capture this Knight and you
get a new structure and whenever the
structure changes you kind of have to
pause and ask yourself how does this
change the position how does this change
the ideas and does this mean I need to
kind of recalibrate what I'm doing do I
need to re readjust and find something
new to do with my pieces and so let's
ask those questions the idea is for
black I think I'm just gonna gonna tell
you are largely the same you still want
to avoid this Bishop kind of ruling your
position so you're still looking to play
moves like c5 and expand on the Queen's
side the difference now is that you're
not doing it to attack the d4 pawn
you're just doing it to gain space to
free your pieces but for white there's
one kind of key difference in the
position that you have to be have to be
somewhat focused on here so yes you're
still going to have the Queen side
pressure you can still play for things
of that nature but one piece in
particular now definitely has the square
it would like to get to and what square
is what square is that and what piece is
that
and it is yep the d4 square okay that's
that's good not quite as ambitious as I
was thinking of d4 is going to be
relevant but it's actually more relevant
to make sure that something like this
doesn't ever happen to you
d4 is a square black should should
really be looking at especially if this
pawn ever is forced to come to the e4
square which we wouldn't like but the
square I'm thinking of is d6 this is of
course a very strong square especially
for a Knights which does have a path to
get there and this is a very very common
idea in conjunction with bringing this
pawn to e5 from e5 this pawn defends d6
and makes 96 a lot closer to being a
reality so definitely that's a very
important idea you want to keep in mind
and that's just kind of a facet of the
structure and this pawn on e5 controls
d6
and so very often you'll see Knights to
try to come in to this square so that's
really the main difference in this
structure compared to to this structure
with the pawn on d4 that I wanted to
talk about so okay first we see Bishop
f4 just preemptively defending this pawn
before a black on pins black then on
pins we do see Knight c3 and so there's
a little bit of a tactical justification
for one if you take this pawn you just
get a little bit pinned up which is
never fun and secondly I think you can
actually get away with capturing on b5
drawing this Queen away and this is
going to be pretty favorable for white I
think this work might come to d8 well
third tries the charm and then after
Bishop f3 there's just going to be a
little bit of pressure on the Queen side
I think and I might have even missed
something better for a 4/4 white here in
fact maybe I can even get away with some
some very very funny business of this
nature taking advantage of the fact that
this
this piece is under pressure so not 95
after Knight c3 but instead we see
Knights c5 is black's idea it hits the
Queen so the Queen moves and now black
takes this opportunity to gain some more
space on the Queen side with the move b4
so White's Knight is attacked and here
of course our goal is to get to d6 so
how can we achieve that what do you
think keep in mind Fabiano is a very
stubborn person who will sometimes go to
great lengths to achieve his goals when
when it's when it's the responsible
thing to do so yeah shout out to all the
European viewers staying up into the wee
hours of the nights to learn some chess
appreciate you guys making the effort so
what are we doing with this Knight how
do we get to d6 what's what's the path
yep yeah obviously right you bring the
knight back to b1 you have a couple
options and you want to get to d6 of
course if if 94 here what would we see
black do ya I'm willing to bet black was
planning to exchange here and simply
play a move like either h6 or g6 in
order to deal with the pressure on that
that side of the board in fact yeah
let's say g6 and then after something
like rook c1 you could expect to see c5
and black is really trying to solve all
of his problems pretty quickly here a
couple pieces get exchanged and then
black is is doing doing quite alright so
instead of 94 Knight be one is fabiana's
move bishop a six is perhaps
preemptively guarding the c-4 square
there's also pressure to e2 so Fabi
plays Bishop f3 to defend it
rook ac8 is now blacks choice and this
move actually might have been a little
bit of a mistake believe it or not
sometimes simpler is better
rooks belong in open files and this
would have been been quite nice for it
for black white can continue with this
move Knight d2 will start rerouting this
night as well and now if Knight c4 I'm
not sure if we could actually expect
white to take it or black to take it
because he's been preparing in another
way to deal with 96
whereas let's say simply rook b8 now
with 96 black is eyeing some some
tactical justifications like like Knight
takes e5 here so the game could have
continued like this this night might
come to be 3 aiming to put some more
pressure on the c5 square in this pawn
and let's just say for example black
does choose to take this pawn now we can
just look at it as a sacrifice for white
and we'll see white try and find some
pressure on the Queen side but black is
probably going to be doing ok you can
expect takes maybe uh yeah we'll say
well mmm Queen Bishop well we'll take it
back somehow and with the opposite color
bishops black is going to be doing okay
here instead though instead of playing a
little bit more actively with 48 we saw
Rick AC 8 which is kind of a strange
move just preparing to push this this
pawn a little bit further down the board
stepping out of this bishops diagonal
but now it gives white and opportunity
to take advantage of blacks a little bit
overextended Queen side so how can we
take advantage of blacks overextended
Queens side how do we do it
as always with these games we're just
looking for ways to activate our pieces
so which pieces are inactive is a good
place to start this night in this rook
so how to activates
nobody knows 92 so 92 is a fine move
yeah probably you could expect a lot of
the similar things to happen things like
97 just to keep an eye on on this pawn
here but there's actually something a
little bit faster a little bit faster
for white
so not quite a four but instead a three
which I think someone has suggested they
wanted to start with Knight d2 and
follow it with a three but a three
immediately I think is is just a bit
better if you do start with 92 let's say
rook d8 gets played and then you play a
3 let's see if I can come up with some
reasonable reason why this this isn't
isn't the best yeah I mean I think this
is this is also probably playable but a
three immediately there's no reason
really not to not to play it yet so they
wanted to play Knight d2 to avoid b3
being played mm-hmm but against b3 Fabio
was probably planning Queen c3 makes the
most sense
and now after 1992 it's going to be
difficult to defend this pawn I kind of
helped why it's caused by playing Knight
d7 for black but let's say even you try
your your hardest to defend this pawn
Knight d2 is going to come and let's say
even you play Queen b6 now Bishop e3 is
going to come and it's it's going to be
tough to maintain this this Knight here
to help well even Queen b7 well we'll
play the same way it's going to be tough
to maintain this Knight on c5 defending
this this nice b3 pawn and so what's
just going to get some pressure from it
in fact though I think this is what
black should have done instead after a
three black kind of tried to admit his
mistake and played rook b8 just a quick
little adjust of the rook after it came
to see it but now of course a takes
before and rook takes before and now
this rook is on a very nice open open
file white continues with Bishop e3 and
after Queen b7 if Bishop takes c5 were
to be played there's this move rook
takes b2 and I'm not sure how all the
tactics are working out just yet
I haven't analyzed this too deeply don't
know if you can tell but
let's ask the computer not rook takes b2
but of course Rick see for instant I'm
sorry rook c4 would be regaining the
peace so we don't see bishop takes e5
instead 92 keeps an eye on the C 4
square renewing the threat to the night
rook takes b2 we see Queen c3 and now it
could be 5 it defends the night here
Fabi missed the best move King g2
instead he simply plays Rakai 3 and the
way he played is very natural so I don't
want to don't want to discount it too
much because it does maintain an edge
and he's simply just activating all of
his pieces Queen b8 was played hanging
this pawn may be Fabi should have taken
it and said he plays her da 1 which is a
again a very natural move just
activating his pieces along this a file
and there's not too much Duda can it can
really do about it here
Bishop b7 was his choice giving up this
pawn on a 7 but once again Fabi is way
too active after 97 we do see this
Knight finally come to c4 and the
dreaded d6 square is in fact looming
rook d8 is his choice white now plays
Bishop efore preparing perhaps and have
for idea just adding more pressure to
the Kings side as well c5 black finally
tries to break free but it's a little
bit too late now Queen c2 makes a threat
black plays h6 this Bishop comes back to
D 2 and now we see night f8 and this
Bishop comes back to d3 and what what
you see here is black has permanent
problems that can never really be solved
those problems being this d6 square
these rooks on the seventh or this rook
on the seventh being very active and his
pieces just not being able to get
coordinated which is why I'm kind of
playing through these moves quickly
these moves are just bobbing slowly
improving his pieces and pointing out
some deficits in the black position for
example this rook not having too many
squares and the rest of black's pieces
not really making sense rook d7 was what
black chose defending this Bishop
preparing 496 taking advantage of this
jerks placement so we see rook b6 and
now Fabi simply captures this pawn on c5
and once again this rook has attacked
Bishop d5 is how black defends it the
now Rick takes d7 and a it takes d7
queen c8 check is a very nice move this
Queen can't be captured due to a fork so
instead Knight back to f8 not not the
happiest move I've ever seen and now
Bobby trades Queens and plays f4 he's
simply up a clean pawn this knight on d6
is very active the bishops are more
active I'm willing to say for hobby as
well and this rook is going to be coming
in two to the seventh rank once again we
see Bishop d8 and Fabi just brings the
King into the game we see Bishop e3 g5
is blacks attempts this Bishop improves
itself to d4 rook could be for King III
bringing the King even closer takes
takes was played we see King f8 now
Bishop b5 and Fabi really does make the
most of the Sun game with some great
technique
Knight f6 is what black tried using
tactical means to take advantage of the
f6 square but Fabi simply captures the
point is rook takes d4 and King takes d4
would be a mistake Judah Bishop takes f6
regaining the rook but Fabi simply does
not recapture instead playing York c1
this renews the threat to the rook the
bishop captures here anyways but now
after work c7 the activity is a little
bit too much if you tried Bishop to e7
two attempts to guard this f7 Square you
are hanging a rook so you can't do that
there's no way to defend it simply
Bishop h8 and now Bobby actually goes
for a cage a check and takes this bishop
if you play King takes d6 King takes d4
once again so the rook moves but now
Knights see a check in Bishop d3 white
has won a piece
using this fantastic activity and the
game is more or less over a couple more
moves were played Bishop e4 and black
resigns Bishop before of course hanging
another Bishop a little bit strange but
this is where due to decided to throw in
the towel so any any questions on on
this game I blew through the latter half
pretty quickly the main point I wanted
to get across with this game was this
use of the d6 square and taking any
opportunity you can to kind of activate
your pieces so that was the the main
focus of this game but with that in mind
any questions about about any part of it
really I'm willing to go over no nothing
not even anything from from the YouTube
chat that's surprising due to losing oh
he's playing Fabi yeah those two
messages go go pretty well together yeah
so I will just quickly review the main
highlights then of the game we do see
Queen b3 is Bobby's new attempt in the
Catalan putting some pressure on b5
rather than c6 is his idea Bishop e7 and
then blacks mistake really didn't come
until later in the game we see this
change in structure Bobby of course
eyeing this d6 square and now after
Queen c7 Knight c3 once again d6 is the
idea and flex mistake comes after rook
c8 he had to play a little bit more
actively to keep this a3 idea at bay of
course rook FD 8 achieves that now if
you play a three here it's a little bit
awkward because you can't recapture this
rook and the D file is is going to be a
bit more relevant in this case and then
of course later on white simply got
active and used that activity to to win
the game with that of Mines thank you
all so much for joining me this week on
the road
mm as always my name is Caleb Denby and
I will see you in the next episode
[Music]